Dizz Miguel concepción editor GameSpot
and reviewer of Ghost Recon wildlands
I'm here to briefly talk about this
Silencio the weapon you unlock when you
defeat El sueño a word of warning there
are spoilers after you power your way to
the mausoleum and open the double doors
a cutscene will play this will lead to
the ending and the end credits now I
would but unfortunately my hands are
full at the moment after the credits
you'll find yourself outside the
mausoleum with a congratulations message
and the Silencio it is a well adorned
shotgun that has decent damage and high
noise reduction by shotgun standards
while we got this for killing El sueño
there is still a lot of leftover work to
do in destabilizing the rest of the
Santa Blanca cartel we're pretty sure
you'll get another gun if you manage to
achieve 100% completion for more tips
and videos go to GameSpot comm and
comment like and subscribe on our
YouTube channel while you're there check
out my review of Ghost Recon wildlands
somebody's gonna down hill that was
messy as [ __ ]